PETER: Why did you
pack it up from California?
Why'd you move from San Francisco
when you're in tech, to Kyiv?
JOHN: Straight off the bat,
not a little foreplay or anything first?
-Zero foreplay on this.
-Okay.
-So what was it? Were you missing...
Was something not right at home?
What was it?
Like, why would you just get up and go?
JOHN: It's a lot of reasons.
The biggest one that initially sparked me
is just knowing a Ukrainian.
I was living in a hacker hideout.
That sort of ghetto hacker house and...
PETER: Ghetto hacker house
in San Francisco?
-Yeah.
-What do you mean ghetto in San Francisco?
-I mean, like, a girl came over
and she's like,
"There's a guy
smoking heroin in the doorway."
and I'm like,
"Oh, don't worry about him." [laughs]
-So this is obviously
the rough part of San Francisco.
Which there is
and most people have no clue about.
-Exactly, people who live in San Francisco
sometimes don't know this place exists.
-Right.
So you met a Ukrainian in there?
-Yes, I met Andre the first night.
He's out on the street
right there when I walk in
-and he says...
-He wasn't doing crack or anything?
-LSD.
-LSD, seriously?
-Eyeballs are huge.
He's like, "Do you want to go
burn Christmas trees on the beach?
PETER: So this was your first
introduction to Ukraine, through Andre?
-Yeah.
-This guy with bugged-out LSD eyes?
-He's a f*cking genius.
Like, later that night
we're hanging out in the common room,
seven or eight of us
and he has his desktop set up there
and he's typing so fast
and we're laughing, joking
and suddenly the typing stops.
So we all look over at Andre.
He's like, "I fixed a bug."
And we're like, "Yeah!"
-You came from San Diego
which is warm, sunny, nice beaches.
So...
Okay, there's startup issues
in San Francisco but...
What else would spark you
to make such a drastic move?
You'd never even been
to this part of the world before.
-One, Maidan was really cool.
I was living with Andre
when Maidan was happening
and that was totally new for me.
And...
Seeing people in the streets
with like shields, and helmets, and fire
that's something that we don't
ever have in America, like at all.
-1865 was the last time.
-Right?
-Oh, yeah.
-Over a hundred years.
-Civil war.
JOHN: And so I actually admired
the Ukrainians because it sounded like
they were essentially betrayed
and they were pissed off,
and they were standing up for themselves.
-Right.
-And to do those kinds of things
you have to be brave.
You have to care about yourself
and about your country
and those people
are kind of like heroes to me.
And so on another level
I thought that Ukrainians
are just cool people.
Like, I admired them
and so that's another thing
that triggered me to go there.
Another one is just knowing Andre
and liking him as a person
and he has kind of some of the esoterical
and hippie vibes as well that I like.
If he's from there then there would
be other people like that from here
and so I knew it would be likely that I'd
enjoy people and have friends and stuff.
-Okay.
-Another reason is girls.
Just liking women.
That's something that's
automatically gonna be attractive here.
It's definitely a factor
but it's hard to separate
everything out together.
Like 100%, it wasn't what drove me here.
When you're adding all the calculations
they just added up to a level where
despite having a good life back home
and not needing to make a move
and all of the risk
and possible discomfort
the calculation just seemed
kind of easy and I have a big goal
and I'm pretty ambitious and I know that
in order to do those things
I have to push my comfort zone
and I have to play my cards right.
PETER: To me it doesn't sound crazy
but I think
to a lot of Ukrainians or Americans
it's pretty drastic.
-Well then you backed it up
because even though it made sense
you had been in Ukraine.
You loved the country
-you spoke highly of it.
-Yeah.
-In our friend group we had some Ukrainian,
Russian, Slavic people that I liked
and they just seemed like cool people.
They're tough, they're smart,
they're just capable.
PETER: You didn't feel any nervousness
of leaving come, coming to here?
There was no apprehension or...
[chuckles]
Like, walk me through it.
-I had a return ticket.
Okay, so coming to here...
Right, the day I'm about to leave
I find out that the Turkish government is
being overthrown, or having a revolution,
and I'm flying through Istanbul.
-Summer 2016?
-Yeah.
So if you believe in signs or anything.
I don’t' really but...
[laughing] it just seemed like a bad time.
[John inhales deeply]
-That was the year
the airport was bombed out too.
-Yeah, it was literally
right after the airport got bombed
that I was supposed to be there
and I'm like...
-Oh well.
-Then the revolution is kicking off.
So you came here.
You landed in Boryspil, the airport.
What were the thoughts?
What were the emotions
running through your head?
Were you like,
"Hell yeah, I'm on to this new challenge."
or were you like,
"Oh sh*t, what am I doing here?"
or what was it like?
-I was really happy to see free Wi-Fi.
That's, like, really cool.
-Free Wi-Fi in the airport?
-Yeah.
-So many places don't have free Wi-Fi.
-Right, right.
True.
-Got in a taxi.
Driver's asking for 500 hryvnias,
whatever that is
and I double checked by cross-referencing
another taxi for the ride
and they also said 500.
So I'm like,
"Cool, I know I'm not being ripped off."
And it turned out
I was being ripped off but...
-So you got into the city center.
Did you have somewhere to go
or where were you going?
-So Andre's company
is taking off a lot
and he has an employee
who was gonna host me.
And so I got dropped off at her place
and it was a pretty warm welcome.
Very cool person.
An attractive female programmer
is something
that's not very common
in American as well.
Which is just like
a sort of nice landing here.
It's not always the case
that you go to a new country
and like, everybody's
down to just help you.
-Right, right, right.
-Uh, and that was just really welcoming.
-Do you think it's what you
put out to the world is what you get back?
Or you think, honestly, here,
people just are open and give more?
-I think it's both.
I think people here
don't count time like in America.
-Right, right, right.
-In America...
There's a little bit more stress
especially San Francisco
'cause things are moving so fast.
It's like if you're not growing,
you're dying.
-I think there's like
overall in the US
there's an anxiety
in the culture of like...
It's this life deferment
mentality of like, you gotta,
"In five years, I'll be doing this...."
"and retirement time,
I'll be doing this." right?
-And that doesn't exist here at all.
-Time is money over there.
-Every second is counted for, yeah.
-Yeah, it's not counted.
People are more patient.
They enjoy conversations for
the sake of conversations a little more.
It seems like people have
less ulterior motives.
It's overall just more relaxing
and I've noticed myself,
by being here I've become more relaxed
and it just seems like
a more genuine real way to live life.
On some levels, being here
compared to America
reminds me of being a child in some ways.
In a good way
where time seems to stop a little bit more.
I can go into an abandoned building
and, like, hang out.
Laws seem a little bit more flexible
whereas in America
if I go in an abandoned building
it's like a big deal and really bad.
-Right, right, right.
-The world's more
fresh and interesting
and here, every block
is its own unique adventure.
In America all the blocks are...
"Wow, there's, like, a McDonalds,
and a Subway, and a Macy's right here."
I've seen a thousand of those before
and they’re all the same.
In Ukraine there's
a lot more interesting stuff going on.
-Like what else
was going through you?
Were you like,
"Okay, I'm just gonna do a week here."?
A year here?
Like, what are you thinking?
-So I think it was about two weeks,
two and a half weeks.
I had a return ticket back and I was like,
"All right, I'm going to
hire a team of developers."
First step.
And then figure it out from there.
And at the same time
I wanted to explore the city
and decide if this
is a place I'd wanna move.
'Cause I knew that if I could move here
it'd be more effective.
Being here, being able to
operate and talk to people.
-So in a way you were
on a kinda scouting trip
to see if you wanted to see
if you wanted to live here instead?
-Yeah, work
and work-pleasure in a way.
Like I was trying to enjoy the city
but for the sake of knowing
if I could work here
and I really liked it.
There was so much raw stuff.
I had got on CouchSurfing
before coming here...
-Yeah.
-And normally
a guy on CouchSurfing is like...
"Hey, can I stay on your couch?"
20, 30 people
and finally somebody says yes.
Here, I made an advertisement...
or just some sort of post.
-Right.
-And about 30 people
reached out to offer to host me.
Like 30 reached out to me.
-Wow.
-And that's like a thousand times
different from other places.
-Dude, they're super...
I find the Ukrainians
super open to foreigners.
Like, they're very open minded to guests.
-Yes.
-And people coming here for the most part.
-And it made me feel welcome.
-Yeah.
-Just these people who are interested...
to hang out, and to talk,
and to show me around.
PETER: You gotta be miserable to uproot...
Uproot your life completely
and go to a different part of the world.
Or what is it?
I could answer this question too
but you go for it.
-Um, I wasn’t sure
but it became pretty clear
pretty quickly that this place just
seems so much more real and authentic.
I felt like there's
a little piece of humanity
that's missing in California
that I found here.
I feel more alive here and...
It's not just that it's good for business.
Like, even if GameTree's blowing up...
-I meant that's...
-Blowing up in a good way.
-Yeah, blowing up in a good way.
It's important for me,
like, that that's...
I see that as a path to my ultimate goals
but I'm gonna try to (buy us)
staying here however much possible.
I've kind of fallen in love
with the country.
I wanna promote the country.
I helped with the Connect Ukraine
Festival. about showcasing
some of the best things
that Ukraine has to offer to foreigners
to invest in the country and get it
more on the international scene.
JOHN: One of the biggest challenges is that
about half of the apartments were fake
-and they were real estatements fishing...
-Seriously?
-To get people to visit
or to get people's contact information.
Like literally about 50% of the listings
are just straight up, fake.
Which I think should be
highly regulated and illegal
and it's very frustrating
'cause I've moved a few times now,
different apartments
and every time
it's just such a pain in the ass.
Getting excited,
seeing the pictures and the price
and then realizing
that they're just fishing.
Like that should not be allowed.
PETER: So that's a big challenge.
What else is a challenge?
Or what were the big challenges
when you moved in?
-So we lived together and you were like,
"Juke, Ukraine's awesome, I'm coming in."
"Save that extra room."
and so I Airbnb'd it out
for a little bit...
-Yeah.
-And there were those
digital nomads cruising though.
They're blogging, traveling a lot.
I thought they'd be a bit tough
from living that kind of lifestyle
but the second that
the hot water cut out...
-Right.
-Which was totally unexpected.
Never seen that in America
but they were flipping out
without hot water.
-Seriously?
-Yeah, like...
A long time ago,
hot water wasn't even a thing.
-Right.
-And I take cold showers
just 'cause sometimes
but for them, that was
like a major inconvenience.
-That was in like the middle
of the summer too, right?
-It was, yeah.
And so that made me...
It was one of the things I noticed
about the difference
between Americans
and Ukrainians is that here
you don't expect
perfect comfort all the time.
-Right, right, right.
-Whereas they're Americans.
Like, they kind of reacted...
It was almost like...
I was almost embarrassed
by how spoiled they were.
That just some cold water
was such a big deal.
-Right, like at the forefront of their day
these creature comforts
and then everything
comes in behind that or something, right?
-Yeah, and to me,
it's like I hardly even notice.
-Dude, I mean, okay...
So if you live here and I'm sure
the cold water thing gets old.
If it lasts for a long time,
say, in the summer in your apartment
but I honestly...
I seriously think
that stuff's good for you
because it breaks you out of...
It's like Ramadan in Islam, right?
-Yeah.
-Like you have to fast.
You have to abstain from sex.
You have to do all these things
that you normally do.
You have to abstain
from all these things, right?
And then when you get those things back
it feels great and you appreciate them.
And I honestly feel like
the few times the power's gone out...
Actually it's only happened
like twice in a little over a year.
My girlfriend and I put the candles on.
It was super cool.
Or the cold shower thing,
I actually don't mind really at all.
So I think these, like...
These breaks in the comfort...
At the end of the day
are actually a good thing.
I mean if we're talking about these little
things we're talking about right now.
-Yeah.
-I remember when
I first moved into your place...
'cause we lived together, what?
Two months?
She came barging through the door.
Started yelling at you for money.
-In Russian, don't know
a word she's saying
and she's yelling at me in Russian
as if I understand something.
-I guess that's your fault, right?
Like, 'cause you're in Ukraine
and you don’t' speak the language.
That's our fault really, right?
But at the beginning
you're not gonna get the language
but what she did was like...
It's like that American guy in Italy.
You ever seen that guy?
With the white socks pulled up to the knee
and the shorts on
and someone doesn't understand him
so he starts speaking
louder and slower and I'm like,
"Hey Rick, no matter how loud
and slowly you speak..."
"If somebody doesn't understand
the language they won't get it."
and that's how she was to you.
She was just like...
-And not slow.
-Not slow.
-Emotional outburst.
-Emotional outburst. [both chuckling]
And she wanted money, and you had
a stack of hundreds in your hands...
Like, "Here's the money."
but she just wanted to rip you apart
for the reason of ripping you apart.
-They brought a translator that time and...
I asked the translator, like,
"Why is she yelling?"
and he's like,
"Oh, she thought you weren't gonna pay."
and I'm like, "Well, clearly the money
is here right now. Why is she still angry?
He's like, "Oh, she just had
a long flight from Chicago."
It's like...
Like I...
-Right, that's an excuse.
-She's acting like a spoiled...
...five-year-old child.
Cranky... You can't, like, yell at people
because you just were on a plane.
-Especially when they have what you want.
So you feel like you've been
taken advantage of here
like just by her
or, like, by a lot of people?
-Mostly just her.
I think the land lords here
are a little bit sketchier
than I'm used to in America.
In America there's a lot of rights for
the people staying in the apartments.
-Especially in San Francisco.
-A little bit more clean and professional.
But here I feel like at least
the property owners I've dealt with
tend to try to be really cheap
and cut corners whenever
and however they can.
-What else, anything else?
-The interiors of
some of the buildings here...
-Uh-huh.
-look like the interiors of...
...a gothic, run-down, punk party.
-Like the entryways, right?
-Yeah,
and the elevators and stairways.
The buildings are beautiful
from the exterior
and the insides can be beautiful
but the common areas
look like abandoned buildings.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
like going into your place...
So it's, like, in a nice part of the city.
It looks beautiful on the outside
and when I go in your place,
like if I was in Latin America
I would be fearful of my life.
'Cause you see the graffiti,
all the cigarette butts, the trash.
You're like,
"This is not a safe place to be."
But it's sort of normal here
for a lot of apartment blocks.
-The last place
I lived as well was like that.
-And the last place
but then you get on the elevator.
Which I don't think there are
any bigger threats in this country
other than these Soviet era elevators.
Seriously, I think if I die here
that's how it's gonna happen.
On one of those elevators.
I've had a few experiences
where I definitely felt, um...
More scared than any roller coaster
or fun thrill-seeking ride.
Just, it's up there
with skydiving, to be honest.
When the elevator comes down,
and, like, jolts
and it doesn't really go on the level
of the floor you're getting off on...
I don't know, that to me, is...
Is one of my biggest fears.
So...
Okay, what about this?
It's like a metaphor
for this country, I find.
Like, it's not always on the surface
but once you get inside
it opens up and shows
its true self or its better self.
-And those entryways...
-Yeah, the contrast.
Those entryways are really
grungy and dirty
but then you go into,
perhaps, an apartment
after like three locks are unlocked
through a bomb-proof door...
-Or two doors.
-And then it's a different world inside.
-Yeah
And this kind of reminds me of that.
Where yeah, they might not have
as good infrastructure
but people there get by and they’re happy
and in America we have infrastructure
but then people just take it for granted
and it's like there's
no point in even having it
'cause it's not making your life better
'cause it doesn't affect
your happiness once you're used to it.
-Hmm, so do you think
the whole goal is your happiness?
That should be your goal in life?
-Somewhat, I think that the happiness
is always relative where
you get used to things.
You're big on this.
About going to Osypenko.
Like, you know by going
somewhere like that it's gonna be hard
but you're gonna appreciate
other things more because of it.
-Due that experience will go down,
I think when I'm old and I'm dying...
Like that will flash through my head as
one of the coolest experiences of my life.
I'm serious, like that was a very
impressionable, meaningful experience.
And I was just back there,
I visited the family.
It's like a second family
I now have in Ukraine.
Which is amazing.
I feel way more connected to here
because of that.
-And from the traditional,
like, human point of view
you should have been miserable.
That should have been
one of the worst experiences of your life
because you went down in lifestyle.
-Yeah...
It ranged more.
I mean I had higher highs
and some lower lows.
I think that's Ukraine in general.
My emotions range more in this country.
Like, I feel more peaks...
[both chuckle]
...and try to look at everything
as an optimist
but, like, definitely
harder valleys sometimes.
You look out the window
and the sky's fusing to the ground
and it looks bleak...
but...
it makes...
It makes it all more interesting I think.
Like you think too, right?
And I think it's also different,
like we have...
Whenever you're doing something different.
So if I was from Ukraine,
if I was young from Ukraine
I'd probably want to go to the states.
At least for a little bit to check it out
or Western Europe just to see
'cause I'm curious.
I'm a curious person.
But, uh...
Yeah, I think when you level things up
you balance things out
like you were talking in the beginning
like, "Okay, this, this, that, that."
For me it works well here,
and home, I have a good life.
In the US, I mean,
I still have a business there.
I have family, friends.
There's tons of opportunity.
It's a beautiful country
but I know it.
I know how it works.
There's no...
My curiosity is not piqued at all.
I know it's around every...
You know, like,
you know what's around every turn
You know how it's gonna operate.
You know the language.
You know the behavioralisms.
Here, is like a...
A little bit of an adventure in the jungle.
-You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-And, like, you're swingin'
from some ropes sometimes
and you don't know
exactly where you're gonna land.
-You literally don't know
what's gonna be around the corner.
Whereas in America you can
kind of predict pretty comfortably
what's gonna be around the corner.
-Because there's more time...
I mean it's not to say people
aren't working long schedules
or busy, or super stressed
but it's different.
I can't really put a thumb on it
but it's different in a sense that
in general, people have
more introspection time.
The look more into deeper things,
into deeper thoughts.
I'm speaking in generalities.
Where in the US
it feels more like a hamster wheel.
You're constantly
running, running, running forward.
Which is great for some things.
It's great for innovation.
It's great for startups.
It's great for
progressing business, right?
But does it lead to
overall happiness in life?
That's a different question, I don't know.
-Yeah, and I think you're
touching on an important point about
in America, having that specialization,
division of labor, Economics 101.
But here, people know literature,
philosophy, history.
So much stuff way better
than the average American
and for somebody, myself,
like, I really enjoy liberal arts.
When I was in university
I went to a pure business school
and half the school was just like,
"What's the point of learning this
if it doesn't make money?".
-People here wouldn't say that.
-Right.
Poets are put up on a pedestal here.
That's, like, I never even knew
that people still appreciated poets.
I thought that was something
from like hundreds of years ago.
[both laughing]
Literally, there's more statues of poets
than there are of presidents in the city.
-I remember when
I visited you the first time.
I was talking to some...
I think he was like 23 years old.
We were talking about
the FARC in Columbia, right?
The Revolutionary Guard.
We're talking about geopolitics,
we're talking about art
we were talking about surrealism,
we were talking about literature
we're talking about life philosophy and...
In general, people have
a wider reach of knowledge.
Maybe that's just Kyiv.
I don't know
but in the capital it feels that way.
Where in America if you want to survive
you have to specialize like crazy.
Like, I guarantee you in the US
there is a guy that knows spoons
better than anyone.
He's devoted his life to spoons.
He knows every.... No one's gonna
touch him in that space, right?
But he might not know
where Ukraine is on a map.
Or other basic knowledge, right?
-My dad is a flashlight guy.
He literally has probably a couple dozen
patents just related to flashlights.
-Okay.
So how's someone gonna compete with that?
-[John chuckles]
In the US, people are comfortable.
Really comfortable
and comfortable people don't do that much
and...
-Yeah, there are a lot of people
not comfortable though, man.
There are a lot of poor people in the US.
There's a lot of drug issues.
-That's true.
-There are a lot of people on the street.
There are way more homeless people
on the streets of San Francisco than Kyiv.
I tell my Ukrainian friends that
and they have a hard time believing that
but yeah, in the tech center of...
You know...
Google, Facebook, Yelp,
all these companies, YouTube
It's like...
Here is way more sound as far as
not as many people
are falling through the cracks
or maybe they
remove them from the streets.
Maybe they put them somewhere,
I don't know.
-I think they're on the outskirts.
-You just don't see it.
We're in the old city center obviously
but in the heart of San Francisco
it's full of bums, man.
-Bums have taken over.
-It's kind of scary.
-There's bullsh*t that comes in other ways
but the bullsh*t just really drops down.
We had, like, people
trying to impress others.
I feel like nobody's really
trying to impress in that sense.
-That's something I've learned
to appreciate here a lot.
That I didn't know
I was gonna appreciate so much.
I'm not much of a bubble kind of person.
Like I know, for example,
a Russian Oligarch's son
that I was friends with in university
and am still friends with.
-Yeah.
-And he prefers the life in Newport Beach.
Where he's living in, kind of, comfort
and there's nothing,
like, too interesting going on
-and he loves the bubble.
-Right.
-Like he consciously doesn't like
seeing antique old buildings
that are kind of rustic
and have a lot of character.
-Okay.
-Maybe it's because he grew up with it.
Maybe we're just somehow different.
-And that's how you grew up though, right?
-You grew up in the bubble?
-Somewhat, yeah. On that side, yeah.
I grew up in Del Mar, San Diego.
Which is like one of the most
bubbly places in the world.
-It doesn't get any more
generic than that does it?
But you feel like there's
a greater calling in you to get out of it?
-Yes, and I think also right now
the world's in a weird state.
Where traditionally,
people want to maintain the status quo.
Maintain the bubble but I think
the millenials now, more than usual
are starting to sense
that it's time for something new.
So I think there's a higher proportion
of people right now
that are sort of waking up to
new possibilities of
drastically different things.
That before would be
completely inconceivable and crazy.
-Hmm.
But there's another thing
about you I think people should know
and something you've
always been proud to tell
or you make it very clear to the world
that you're polyamorous, right?
-Yeah.
-Many lovers.
-So walk me through that, man.
Because look, you're going from...
...in that sense, the most liberal
open part of the world
for that way of life, right?
Polyamory, many lovers.
In San Francisco there are
a lot of swinger couples, right?
That's popular there too.
Sex clubs, sex dungeons,
like, sex parties.
-Sex dungeons?
-Yeah.
-Sounds dark, um...
You had a relationship there
that was polyamorous.
-Two polyamorous relationships.
-You had many... Okay.
So you come to this part
of the world, the former Soviet Union.
Where values are
more traditional than San Francisco.
Polyamory would not fly where I grew up.
That would be looked down upon for sure.
-I think 99.9% of people
on the planet could say that.
-Define it. Define it so other people
that might not know what it is.
-So poly means many, amory means love.
So it's many loves.
It's essentially the idea that love
doesn't have to be limited to one person.
It doesn't have to be monopolized or held
and it's possible to have
more fluid relationships
or more complex relationships
than just one man with one woman
or one man, one man, or whatever.
It's just the idea that you don't
have to abide by this social custom.
I think it's better for some people.
It's not as good for others but ultimately
I'm pretty sure that 99% of our evolution,
that's how we grew up.
So it's not something too crazy
and I think it's unfair to the people
where that comes more naturally to
that that should be an option for them.
-Well I think it's honesty, right?
Like you've always been,
from what I've known of you...
You've always been straight up,
like, if you're on a date
you tell the girl
you're polyamorous, right?
-Yeah.
-From the get-go?
-I won't bring it up
like the first thing I say to them.
Sometimes they'll know ahead of time.
Other times I'll bring it up
at a tactical moment
just because it's so taboo here
that I really have to frame it.
Like, I could say the exact same
information to somebody
and that same person
could perceive it as like,
"Oh, this person's a horrible monster."
or
"Oh, that's actually
really interesting and cool."
So I can't just be non-tactical about it.
Especially with women here
who are bred from day one to
get married and have kids
as young as possible.
And for even me, it was a big process of
having to learn, having to mature
and grow to be able to manage that
and it's all about trust
and communication at the end of the day.
If you're being sneaky about stuff
or not being forward about things
-that creates suspicion, jealousy...
-Right.
-There's mysteries that people
want to fill in the blanks
when they're uncomfortable
until they know things.
-Well, it's fair to say there's a lot of
polyamory going on here,
or anywhere really.
-It's just not being spoken, right?
-Yeah
-Like how many people have you met
that cheat on their partners?
-I think at least half of guys here
are cheating on their partners.
From what I can tell.
-Which is kind of a lot.
-What about at home?
-I think less.
I don't know that many people
who cheat back home.
They'll break up or something
but here it almost seems standard
or not a big deal.
-So in gen... like...
With that observation, you're saying
half the male population
is polyamorous in Ukraine?
-Well, they're having open relationships
where they can sleep with other people.
It's kind of like a cousin of polyamory
and you can have polyamory where
you can't sleep with other people
but only partners.
The thing is there's no
black and white answer to it
because it's different for everybody.
Some person could be polyamorous
and be in a monogamous relationship
their whole life
but they believe in the opportunity that
if they met somebody else,
they're allowed to explore that.
-Would you say
it's a challenge for you here?
-Oh, yeah.
But it's...
[Peter chuckling]
It's not something I can't do.
It's for me...
And this is just me speaking
from my perspective right now
but it almost feels like
some level of enlightenment.
Where once you get there
you can't go backwards
and while polyamory is something
I never imagined in my whole life...
I never even, like,
considered or thought of as real.
I mean my great grandfather had a wife.
Went away on a work campaign.
Came back with a second wife and more kids
and back then that was normal
in the Ottoman empire.
The first wife poisoned
the second wife and the kids.
That was my interpretation
of multiple wives.
Is like, "That stuff happens."
So I never even considered it a reality
but being in the Bay Area
on the dating site, OkCupid.
I noticed there was a high correlation
between people I thought were interesting
and confident, or sort of,
very progressive and this concept.
And just over time it was like,
"Hmm, that seems like it makes sense."
"I don't know people like that but..."
"...logically, it seems like
a way that people should be."
-So you're okay...
If you're amorous you're okay with
your partner going with other guys?
-Yeah.
I'll still have jealousy but over time it's
something that I've gotten to curb more.
I went to Burning Man,
took a workshop on overcoming jealousy.
Talking to people...
-'Cause I...
-A prior partner, Manson...
She was naturally polyamorous
ever since she was 12, 13.
It just made sense to her
and that was a good role model.
Was being with her
because she was older than me
and had been polyamorous for many years.
And seeing it functional.
Like she was married, has kids,
very happy, functional family
and having that experience
of getting to know the husband
and actually thinking
he's a really cool guy
-and being friends with him.
-So wait, wait, wait...
You got know the hu...
She was married, had kids,
and you got into a relationship with her?
-It was not something I ever planned
or imagined in my life.
That I would be standing
before a girlfriend's kids
who are like kind of close to my age.
-And the husband was cool with this?
-He was, and it's all about people's needs.
For her, she requires a lot of
emotional death and dynamism.
He's a more stable person that
doesn't have a lot of complicated needs
and so she appreciates that in him
but it doesn't meet those other needs.
You're options are to cheat or break up
or you can be polyamorous
and have everything.
-Whoa.
-So he was okay with you
coming into the household and... [laughs]
...spending time with his wife?
-It sounds crazy and it was
f*cking terrifying going in there...
Like, meeting him the first time.
He's a senior software engineer
but he does martial arts,
has tattoos and stuff.
It was a little intimidating but I didn't
ever get a single negative vibe from him.
Like literally ever.
I...
He's just, like, such an awesome guy.
So if you're saying it's
a level of enlightenment...
Then, [sighs] I don't know
because I would not...
For example, my girlfriend,
if she went with another...
No way I could ever do that...
It's a level of enlightenment
for some people.
Some people, I think, just aren't
hard-wired to ever be polyamorous.
-Yeah, I wouldn't be able to handle that.
-But for some people who can,
it's still going to be a difficult journey.
I had times where I was so stressed out.
So much anxiety, some of the worst
in my life because of polyamory
but it gets easier and easier
as time goes on.
I dated a porn star for a little while...
[Peter laughs in disbelief]
And that made some of it easier
knowing that she was madly in love with me
and even though she'd
share her body with other people...
-Isn't a porn star
madly in love with everyone?
-No, what?
[both laughing]
-Maybe she can act it on camera.
But that was really stressful
the first time a friend took me
out of the house
and he was like,
"You need to get your mind off this."
and we went out
around the city doing stuff.
Just so I wouldn't be pacing
and constantly anxious
the first time she was out on a shoot
but I think that
warmed me up to it a little bit
knowing that sex and love
aren't the same thing.
-Sex and love are not the same thing?
-It can be but they don't have to be.
-But isn't it so much better if you're
having sex with the woman you love?
Yes and no, like...
Yes, it can be but that doesn't mean
you can't appreciate other kinds of things.
You can think, like,
"Oreo cookie milkshakes..."
"are the best kind of milkshake."
That doesn't mean you
only ever want to have
Oreo cookie milkshakes
for your entire life.
-Do you think
it's something you'll grow out of?
You'll get older and you're like,
"Ah, that doesn't interest me as much."
-I think it's possible
but at this point it doesn't seem like
it's something that's possible
but who know?
Ultimately, to me...
Polyamory has been
really nice because one,
I have a strong need
for adventure, curiosity, variety
and on the other hand,
just need fulfillment.
Like on the one hand I want somebody
really in the moment, playful, visual.
Somebody that can be
a very similar opposite to me
that I can appreciate
those parts of life through her
but at the same time I also want
somebody who's sort of a partner in crime.
Somebody who has
a similar alignment and vision
and we can strategize
about a lot of subjects.
I'm gonna go for the things that I want
and if I'm not,
I'm just gonna be miserable.
PETER: It's about staying true to yourself?
JOHN: Yeah.
PETER: Keeping it real?
JOHN: And if I'm not true to myself...
Probably gonna cheat,
get divorced, have, like dark thoughts
but having everything being
honest and open is
I think, a much cleaner,
easier way to live.
So what, um...
Tell me about the journey you've had here
with building a development team.
Why you'd come here to do it.
'Cause you were on
the front lines of tech in San Francisco.
So it seems a bit counter-intuitive
that you'd come to Ukraine
to start your tech company.
When that's pretty much
where it's all happening right now.
-Yeah, it's hard at first
because a little bit of language barrier
and also just not knowing a lot of people.
Not knowing "Where do I post jobs?".
-But why? Why then?
Why would you do it here?
-I would open a company here because...
-Well, you have.
You've got your team going here.
-The people...
The developers in Ukraine are smart,
they're creative, but they work at prices
that are way more affordable
than San Francisco or California.
-Right.
-For equal price, it's just simple
supply, demand business 101.
And especially as a startup
those things matter extra
because unlike Coca-Cola who has,
basically, infinite money to throw around
or Apple, who's sitting on
tens of billions of dollars.
-Right.
-A startup, by it's nature,
it's biggest weakness
is that it just doesn't have
all the cash and resources.
I've worked with people in China,
and in India, and a lot of other countries
and a lot of the times if there's something
not in the specifications,
they just won't do it.
Like, if it's obvious there should be
a back button they just won't put it in
but here people will push back,
they will add things that are common sense.
-They're more intuitive?
-Yes.
And I appreciate that a lot.
Where I'm not much of a micro manager.
I'm a big picture thinker
and I can't do all the details
and think of
everything else in the startup.
So having people here that are
more like co-founders
than just cheap labor is really nice.
-Right, and you're team is all...
I mean it helps for you that you're in an
industry that a lot of young people like.
Which is gaming.
So your team seems to me,
from whom I've talked to
excluding Igor,
who said he quits by the way.
You weren't around.
[silence]
But...
They seem pretty fired up
and passionate about the project
'cause they love gaming
and you're providing that outlet.
It's really fortunate
to be doing that space.
-Yeah.
-Overall, what I'm working on is
a much bigger vision than just gaming.
The game is a good entry point
and there's a lot of things in life
that there's a lot of correlations.
Like there's certain kinds
of games that you'll like.
Certain kinds of people, you'll have
different kinds of relationships with.
There's a lot of algorithms
based on these buckets.
It's not a hard science
but it's useful to have mental models.
-My girlfriend's personality type matches
my personality type well, do you think?
-For example, you're an extrovert
and she's an introvert.
-That's pretty common.
-Right.
-And it seems like it's counter
to a lot of the conventional wisdom.
Like, "Be with somebody the same as you
or similar to you."
But a nice thing is that
you like being more talkative
and if there's somebody more quiet
who enjoys listening a bit more
then that creates a good synergy.
-There's a good... Yeah, there's no
competition between us in anything.
Like, I fill in where she's not there.
She fills in where I'm not.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
And so that stuff's really useful
considering how important
people, and communication,
and meeting people are in our lives.
It's something that gets
very disproportionately
small amounts of attention.
And so a lot of what GameTree is about is
using this knowledge to educate us
about ourselves, our predispositions.
Knowing the lens,
the microscopes, the telescopes
that we're seeing the world through
and having clear
understanding of ourselves.
How we're biased to view other people.
How other people are viewed.
How to appreciate those kinds of people.
There's just so many levels.
-So through your app...
Someone's interested in a game and they can
meet someone that
has their same personality type
or a different personality type.
At least they know
and they can connect with that person.
-So they can find
specific kinds of people saying, like,
"Oh, I have this friend group and I want
somebody who's kind of like this."
They could actually filter
and find these exact kinds of people
in ways that you could never
otherwise meet so easily.
Knowing this personality psychology
with gaming is especially interesting
because you can see
what's fun for somebody.
That correlates highly
with their psychology.
Not everybody has
the same definition of fun
but as children, we play,
we grow, and develop through games.
-Sure.
-And so in a way, it's a great way
to find friends, build relationships,
and continue growing
And there's a strange
social stigma right now around that
that makes that seem less appropriate
but at the same time,
play is what makes people happy
and creates a lot of
the most authentic relationships.
-What do you think of
the art situation here?
-I find that where
there's a lot of emotions
you find a lot of the most interesting art.
A lot of the...
The source material that creates poetry,
that creates analogies
comes from our feelings
and because Ukraine's in a place
where there's such stark contrasts
and there's revolutions
and there's a war going on
that this is a place
that has a lot of emotions.
And so I think that that's the reason why
there's so many
beautiful installations and graffiti
and people trying to express
all these things that they're feeling.
-I find...
Okay, another culture that does this...
I noticed in Egypt after their revolution
the contemporary art museum there
was mind-blowing.
It was all from the youth
all art from the youth, and similar to...
The art's different but it's similar
in the sense that you have
the youth doing a ton of...
At least these art installations...
There aren't a lot of museums here,
there are a few
but it's definitely...
It's coming out them.
Which is cool to see on the streets.
I feel like Southern California
is famous for art, like San Diego
but the art there is a lot of galleries
and putting your paintings up
and it's like, "I want to be an artist
so I can paint things."
but I feel like the artists here...
It's like, "I have to express something
and I'm gonna do it however I can."
and that creates a really authentic, raw
very easy to appreciate,
emotionally rich kind of art.
That is fascinating.
That I did not expect here.
-Well I think you get to a point
in the human experience
where you have to get
what's inside of you out or it kills you.
So for example, nothing I do right now
brings me monetary reward.
Like this or, like, writing,
but I have to get it out of me
or there's this pent up
frustration inside me.
-We're taught to be consumers.
We're a consumer society
but every person is just as much
a creator as a consumer
and it sucks when the most fun part of life
is sort of swept under the rug.
Where suddenly instead of being somebody
who's making shoes for your friends
you're a person is Southeast Asia
working in a shoe factory
with harsh conditions living miserably.
-But don't you...
There's also a level too, where...
If you consume too much and don't
create enough, there's a void, right?
-Yeah.
-I think for me, the more I create
the better I feel actually.
-It's like you
spend energy to get energy.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, Juke.
-One thing I'm really
excited about with GameTree
is that by giving
personalized recommendations
based on people's tastes
and on their psychologies
you can discover the really niche part
that really speaks to you the most.
-Right.
-That you might never know about
through all the mainstream
large-scale advertising
and at the same time
it's a big opportunity.
Possibly an unprecedented opportunity
for small artists
to actually make a living
or to get some traction
doing the things that they're doing.
Whether you're making films,
or fashion, or video games
you can't afford to do the AAA advertising
because it's a really niche product..
The production budget isn't there
but if through GameTree
and eventually expanding this
to be recommendations for all things.
It's actually a massive opportunity
for artists to make a living
doing the things that they love
and for people to consume
higher levels of content.
Where they can actually
engage with the artists
and have more real
authentic human connections.
All right, broski.
PETER: Okay, Ukraine is...
Let's face it,
it's known in the world for corruption.
From the top levels.
I think it permeates
all the way through society here.
As a startup founder...
As a person new to this country
have you dealt with any issues
as far as corruption goes?
-Fortunately, it's been
a complete non-issue here.
-Yeah.
-Very luckily, but I do know it exists
and I've heard instances,
and I know Ukrainians who it affects
and it seems to really suck a lot.
For example I know somebody
whose family home...
is falling apart.
-Yeah.
-There's cracks in the wall,
refrigerator stopped working
because they're building a giant illegal
structure that's not zoned for the area
and her family complained
to every possible agency.
The police, like,
all the government institutions
and nobody was doing anything
and eventually
the police responded and said,
"Just drop it,
there's powerful people building this..."
"...and it's good if you just
don't do anything about it."
and some activist, like a local activist
got involved and was helping...
-Uh-huh.
-...and her tires got slashed and her cat
was found dead in her back yard, murdered.
And...
That's so f*cked up that you have
very blatant transgressions of the law.
Where everybody is just
turning the other cheek.
That doesn't happen in America.
For all of our vices...
We have, like, legal corruption
but just to have something
so blatantly illegal going on
is really infuriating.
That people are
getting away with stuff like that.
-But it doesn't affect you currently?
-Correct, yeah, like starting the company
here I've had no issues with anything
-Okay.
-If you buy a water or something
at the store, people are ripping...
-Oh, they don't, even the babushki
on the street that are giving us flowers.
They could charge us
at least five times more for the flowers
or at least try,
thinking that we're complete tourists
but people here have a lot of integrity
and especially seeing that contrast
having gone to Sri Lanka
where people have more wealth.
That people here
tend to have a lot more civility.
-Yeah, it's weird how that works
in different cultures.
So if you go to China or Vietnam...
It's very blatant, they're gonna get
whatever they can out of you
and that's part of the culture,
it's baked into the culture.
Even Vietnam had a law,
like, foreigners get charged more.
That was eradicated
but still in the mentality
Here, I haven't dealt with it at all.
Not that I know of, and I'm pretty on it.
Know the prices pretty well, but I haven't
dealt with anyone trying to rip me off.
Which is super cool when
you're in a country and you don't, like...
I think that's the biggest resistance
when you're an outsider
'cause there is some assimilation process
and we'll never fully be assimilated.
We'll never be Ukrainian
by any stretch, right?
Even if you and I speak perfect Ukrainian
we'll never be Ukrainian, right?
And there's an assimilation
or a welcoming by not trying to rip you off
in every transaction.
When you get ripped off in every
transaction you make it's just, like...
It makes you feel like an outsider.
There's no way around it.
Here's another
good point of this country.
They're not gonna deal with any
radical, fundamentalist, Islamic BS.
This is not on ISIS's map.
Kyiv, you know what I mean?
-You're not a target here.
-Nah, like Western Europe, America.
Where there's these cultural frictions.
There's none of that here.
I have to say it's pretty homogenous.
It's probably, what?
98% white and Ukrainian?
I would guess something like that.
There are no racial issues
just because there are no races really.
-That's actually one of the perks,
I think, to working here.
It sounds horribly
politically incorrect to say
but it's actually a lot easier
to operate a company
where I don't have to be
as concerned about there being, like...
A black person,
and, like, a Chinese person,
and just, like, in every shot
or every picture.
-Yeah, so I think
in this space we live in
let's just call it a vacuum
'cause in a way it is.
We don't have to cohere
to home and expectations
and the cultural norms, right?
And we're not Ukrainian
and we never will be.
So you're in this space as a foreigner.
I think that's why a lot of expats like it.
Some are escaping...
A lot are escaping something, right?
For sure.
Maybe I'm escaping the fact that, um...
I don't want to be around
the same conditions
that I've been around for a long time.
They're just not as interesting, right?
Like, I want the adventure
and my curiosity piqued
and that exists here
where it doesn't exist at home anymore
'cause I understand how the thing works.
The system, the language,
what's around the next turn.
You get how it works.
Here I don't totally get it
so there's mystery in that, intrigue
and then I'm challenged.
So...
Yeah, I just find by being a foreigner
in a country like Ukraine
you can live a very free existence.
The marketing machine
doesn't hit us, right?
'Cause I can't read
these Ukrainian ads, right?
I don't watch TV.
So none of these messages...
Like, America's the worst for this, right?
It's the worst and the best, right?
It's the best marketing
and advertising machine there is, right?
And it's so curated into our society
and the fabric of our every day life
that you become
sort of immune to it, right?
But also it's constructing how you,
sort of, operate in a way
and here it's like all that is removed.
Like, there's no marketing coming at me.
I don't know the big brands here.
-I don't really care.
-It's less distractions.
-So many less distractions
and also shopping...
Shopping is
an absolute nightmare here, right?
Um...
The big store here, what is it called?
Metro, or something?
Metro?
I don’t know, one of the big box shops.
It's like the Walmart, right?
It's so poorly organized.
There's, like, a fork in this department
and then half kilometer away
there's another fork, right?
And it's so frustrating to shop in that.
I hope to never go again.
And things are just...
There's no Amazon culture here.
There's no purchasing immediately.
Some impulse purchase online
is showing up at your house that day
and you can return it if you want, right?
So, like, I hate shopping
but the whole materialism thing
is somewhat gone.
Like removed.
-Something I do notice
about people here is there are a lot of
really talented artists,
engineers, creative types
but they're missing the business
and I don't know if it's from
the Soviet Union not doing that
or kind of being sided with Russia.
Not accessing Western markets a lot
but people here build a lot of great things
that don't make it out of the country.
In America we have very few
products and companies
that are coming from Eastern Europe
proportionate to how much
of the population of the West they make up.
-Sure.
-I think the American dream is the idea
that your children can have
a better life than you have
and that even if you're born poor,
you can rise up and be somebody
who's very successful
in one sense or another.
-And it's still great for that,
I really feel that.
-It seems like it
but if you look at numbers
comparing it to Scandinavia,
and Switzerland
and a lot of other countries
America is actually sliding down
on that scale quite a lot
but we have this delusion that
a lot of the Republican Party puts out.
Where they make people think
that things are individual people's faults
or that that dream is still alive
or that not taxing corporations
or doing all these things are good
but they're just complete,
blatant, unsupported lies.
-Where do the big innovation makers...
Where do the...
Where did the guy that started WhatsApp,
from Ukraine, where did he go?
Why does everyone go there
if it's so terrible?
It's the best ecosystem
to bring your idea...
It's the best cultural ecosystem
to get money for it and to actually...
It's the best market
to bring it out to the world.
-America has a lot of risk-takers.
-It's founded off risk-taking.
The whole design of the place
is risk-taking, right?
-People with ADHD,
Attention Deficit Hyperactive Disorder...
-You have it, right?
-Are more likely to move.
They're more likely to invent things.
America, like half the population
practically has ADHD.
-Yeah, that's...
-Here, most people
don't even know what that is.
They've recently proven with brain scans
that it's actually
a disorder that people have.
I don't think it's a disorder.
It's a different way of thinking
that's not as accustomed
to sitting at a desk
and rote memorizing things.
It's more about exploring the world,
and being open, and inventive.
-Sure.
-But that's considered a mental handicap
in the way our system is
but that sort of thinking,
when you have more investors
more innovators, more people
who are supporting entrepreneurs
and thinking, "Oh, that's cool
that you tried to take a risk."
Here you have a lot more people
who are like,
"Oh, don't take risks because if there's
another [unclear], you're dead here.
'Cause a lot of people here,
they don't have strong business skills
and they don't have
a lot of strong leadership skills.
In the past, a lot of people
were persecuted or killed for sticking out
and I think that happened
so much for so many years
that maybe it's even
suppressed an entire generation.
For example, Maidan.
Instead of ending up with a lot of change
and a lot of leaders coming out
it was just the same deck of cards
shuffled in a different order.
And so...
In a way I feel like...
More foreigners coming here,
even though it's kind of bad
in that it's not local.
It's actually really good for the country
because they're gonna be
bringing in, not just in money
but they're gonna be mentoring
and teaching these skills
and inspiring other people around them.
-Yeah.
-Who otherwise don't have good examples.
-But okay, no country,
person, place, has it all, right?
So the strong skill sets here are,
like, you have strong math and sciences.
I'm speaking in generalities, right?
Strong math and sciences...
Umm...
Intelligent people.
I find them more philosophical in general.
They can go deeper into
analytical thinking about different issues.
Approaching things
from different angles, right?
And America is better on
the whole capitalism thing obviously
'cause it's baked into the DNA.
That's what it's built on, right?
So yeah, if you can fuse those two together
I think you have something very powerful.
-Young people here,
they're very optimistic.
A lot of them have very good English.
Ukraine's...
-We're talking about the center of Kyiv.
-Yeah.
-Right.
-Ukraine's the third or fourth biggest
outsourcing country
in the world for technology.
-Uh-huh.
-Despite not being
the third or fourth biggest population
and that makes people here have a lot more
outward focus compared to Russia.
Where the average programmer
makes more money, for example.
They have a bigger internal culture,
and they have their own
supply and demand internally
but Ukraine is a lot more global
and that's something that's nice.
Just having that sort of mindset
and with that comes,
I think, a lot of optimism.
-You think it's a more open-minded place?
-I do. A lot of young people here
hold very similar opinions to me
or to a lot of San Franciscans.
A lot more than I would think
from a place where not too long ago
women were, and still are, slightly,
but being taught to get married
and have babies as soon as possible.
Usually you find that sort of thing
in third world countries.
-Well it's here for sure.
Like more than the heart of the Arab world.
More than Damascus.
When I spent time there before the war.
More than Cairo.
More than, I'd say, Istanbul.
Like here, there's a pressure on women
to have children very young.
I don't know where that comes from exactly.
-It's not everybody but I think
it does exist a fair amount.
I think a lot of it's from
a lot of men dying during the Soviet Union.
World War I and II.
Where if so many of the men
die from different epidemics...
-Sure.
-'Cause men disproportionately
die all the time whatever happens
and then it creates
a lot more competition for men
and so a lot of the men here,
I think are spoiled.
They're taking care of a lot.
The women work hard
and the guys take a lot for granted
and I think that's part of why
women want Western men
is because Western men
will try harder to please them.
Whereas otherwise the guys here
are (disincentivized)
because it's a disproportionate
amount of women
and they've been brought up and bred
to take disproportionate care of the men.
So actually, here,
the personality psychology,
a lot of it that I follow the most
is actually already really famous.
It's considered a science
in Eastern Europe.
Which is known as socionics here.
An interesting contrast
between it here and in the West
is that here it's mostly used by women
to know the personality dynamics
about who is a good mate for them
or what are their best partners.
-Sure.
-In the West it's mostly about jobs.
What are the jobs I could have?
How does this apply
to work and managing people?
I think that really shows
a lot about the cultures.
About relationships and happiness
versus work, in that...
But it's the same framework.
It's based on Carl Jung.
Where essentially it's about figuring out,
"How do people think?"
"What energizes them?"
and those, by default
become their strongest tools
and based on how we think,
that's how we're gonna solve problems,
how we're gonna perceive the world,
and what's fun to us.
-Right.
-But what I wasn't expecting as much
is on the soft side.
For example, during Maidan
I really looked up to the Ukrainians
thinking, like, "Wow, I really respect
and admire these guys."
"They're like heroes."
I like to imagine that I would be somebody
who would stand up during that time
but you never know...
But in America you don't really have
those sorts of opportunities.
The most that's gonna happen is people
clicking share on Facebook
and grumbling,
and having circular conversations.
Agreeing with all their friends
about something in bubbles.
-Yeah, American was
shaken up in 1865.
That was the last time really.
But it has its own stresses and weirdness.
Which is, for example,
all these school shootings.
That's mental, man.
Like, that doesn't exist
in this part of the world.
I haven't heard of anyone walking in...
A kid walking in with a semi-automatic
and just spraying bullets on other kids.
That doesn't exist.
-I think that capitalism was a great system
that got us through a time
when there was scarcity
but it's also a disease at this point.
Any mental illness
can be considered a disease
as long as it's not appropriate
for the current environment.
-Mm-hmm.
-And so while capitalism
was a good system for our past
we're in an age now
where we have global camaraderie.
We have friends around the world.
We have technology
to make good decisions, lots of resources.
-Sure.
-Suddenly we could start
operating much more efficiently.
Starting to see our neighbors
more as friends.
Caring about strangers.
That, according to capitalism
is kind of crazy.
Where we're taught
that every person is a competitor
in a battle for scarce goods
but people don't actually have
infinite wants and needs.
They're willing to sacrifice
for other people
and in a place like Ukraine
where capitalism isn't quite as pervasive
I think that's what leads to a lot more
of the well-rounded curiosity about life.
Not counting minutes as much.
About people just being more people
to each other on some levels.
Being a lot more real, not putting on
fake faces for first impressions
or to be liked, or to climb socially.
You get a lot of the hoarding mentality
unfortunately as well from scarcity
but because the capitalism...
-Here?
-Yeah, especially the oligarchs
who hoarded money, they sit on it.
They're not really investing it
back into the communities a whole lot.
But for the most part
I think that the people here
while not being as good
at marketing and business
because of less-developed capitalism
are actually a little bit happier
in a lot of ways
because of the more relaxed connection
to life that they have because of it.
-I totally... I totally agree.
That's...
I can't explain that to people here.
You just said it perfectly
but when I say it's less...
just manic and anxious ridden.
Nobody believes me
and the anxiety, I think,
comes in a different way.
There are more stresses for basic needs.
I think for a lot of the population
but there still doesn't seem to be
the manic battle for time
and one place to look at,
like, if you take a snapshot of a society.
Look at parks, right?
Are there people, normal people,
hanging out in the parks, right?
Okay, we can say
San Francisco's got great parks
and there's society
hanging out in the parks
but I'm gonna say
a snapshot of the US in general
parks quite often have a lot of bums...
[scoffs]
A lot of feces.
It's not a place for,
say, normal or educated...
Say, successful people to hang out in.
And when you walk in the parks here
they're super uplifting.
For the most part, uplifting, positive,
and very human experiences, right?
Like all the guys playing chess
at this Shevchenko park, right?
Like, all these old guys
come out and play chess
and I just watch sometimes
and there's community in that
or people sitting on those chairs
just conversing and taking breaks.
-There's so much more life.
-It feels more human, man.
Where I feel, San Francisco...
I love it and there's so many great things
and I'm not saying what's better or worse
but there's more of that...
That grind and that pull.
-Through a TV screen
you can see staged happiness.
Through economics you can see
people having more stuff
for working relatively
about the same amount
but there are those hidden costs.
-America is very easy to show tangibly.
Like in a iPhone, in Facebook,
in these movies that people see on TV.
There's no way to show that feeling
that you just described a little bit ago.
On the streets...
There's no way to package that
and ship that off
to show to another country.
You have to either come here, feel it,
or what I've been trying to do
through my content is, like,
show it through stories or write about it
and, like, really unearth what that is.
'Cause again, you can't put it in something
you can touch, taste, and feel.
-In America we move around a lot.
We get different jobs.
We're kind of fragmented.
We lose a lot of our tribes
and even our families.
I don't think the average American
talks to their families that much
but in Ukraine I feel like that base...
That not only gives you
some level of support
but also a lot of love and general
necessary satisfaction
for human well-being
is a lot stronger here.
A lot of Americans, the reason
that they're trying to seem so happy
and follow all the latest
health trends and everything
is because they feel sad and alone.
A lot of that's why I'm starting GameTree
is because it's so hard to find
that solid group of friends
if you're moving around a lot
from place to place
but I've noticed that
people here, on average,
do have a lot stronger bonds
with their friends and family.
And that's something
that's just, at the end of the day
when people are on their death bed
say is the most important thing.
-It's true.
Yeah, well said.
-You can go to a doctor here and...
It's gonna cost, like, $13.
-In America it's gonna cost a few hundred.
-You have to pay a bribe
and he might be drunk.
This is a possibility of this happening.
-The healthcare here
is much better despite everything.
-Dude, how about this...
The healthcare is better here
if you need little things.
If you need little things done
and to go to a doctor, it's better here
and it's way more manageable.
If I need brain surgery done,
my brain's totally off...
I wanna go to Stanford
or like the top medical center in the US.
It's funny you say weed because that...
One of the observations I noticed early on
was weed is considered a hard drug here.
Like, drugs are put in one category.
Like, heroin, cocaine, weed,
are in one basket, right?
And where we're from it's legal right now.
You walk into a store just like
you're gonna buy a bottle of alcohol.
You walk in, you choose what you want.
You pay the cashier,
you get a bag, and you leave, right?
-Here it's...
-It's almost like we've...
PETER: It's all perspective, right?
And it's all how we've been conditioned.
So now we're conditioned in California
or a handful or other states in the US
where it's completely okay
to purchase in the open.
It's accepted.
Here it's not accepted at all I found
and I smoke weed probably
five, six times a year.
I don't even drink anymore.
But that's, like, my escape,
five, six times, have a little weed...
JOHN: My personal purpose is to help
fix some things I see
fundamentally broken in society.
That are universally broken
in a capitalist system
but that's what led me here.
Through GameTree,
the company that I'm starting.
I see if I play my cards right, having
a route that can help a lot of people.
What I didn't expect so much
was to actually fall in love
with the country itself.
With the people here.
Finding a home here
and wanting to stay here.
Like, that wasn't as big a part of
the equation when I originally came here.
Everybody loves an underdog,
myself being no exception.
It's like a universal human trait
and I think that Ukraine
just doesn't get their fair share.
It has a government
that's somewhat corrupt.
So other countries
don't want to deal with it.
It has Russia invading
so it looks like the place is at war.
A hot potato that nobody wants to touch.
But the fact is that
this place is a real hidden gem.
The streets are clean.
Society is very civil.
The people are creative and smart.
The prices are phenomenal.
To me, this is literally the best place
in the world to be, on a lot of levels
and that's not something I totally expected
outside of a business realm.
And so that's what's really
made this place a home for me
and somewhere that
I'm actually continuing to stay
despite the potential to now
maybe go somewhere else
and just manage remotely.
When I first came here
I was half thinking I would build a team
and then go back home
or go somewhere else.
-Right.
-But within a few days
just seeing how raw, and real,
and how much potential is in this place
and how much beauty there is
that I wasn't expecting
has made me want to be a Ukrainian myself.
And it's just another way of, like...
-Would you... You wouldn't get rid of
your American side?
-I can't because that's where I'm from
but when I see somebody
like Donald Trump...
Trumping around America, it's embarrassing.
-Embarrassing sh*t but also, like...
The leadership here
is pretty embarrassing too.
-That's true but Trump's like...
He's like... [both laughing]
-He's an absolute catastrophe.
-Um...
A lot of people are coming to Ukraine
for cheap prices and women.
And...
It kind of reminds me of,
like, a Vietnamese brothel.
When you put it that way.
And it's kind of sad for me
because the people here
have so much creativity
and brightness in them
and I somehow want people to know
that that's not what it is for me.
Even though that's such a clear thing
that people know about this place
but I think that this place
really is special
and has so much more to offer.
-Sure.
I mean I lived in Thailand,
I lived in Bangkok.
You know the stereotype of Bangkok, right?
-Yeah.
-And I loved the city.
And there is that side of it,
there is that whored-out side to it
but actually in Thai culture
it was seriously frowned upon.
Like, it's actually...
Thai culture, in a way, is conservative
and I lived in a completely different
universe on that front
but I always saw people
were representing...
I mean people were
referring to the Thais as this
and how that can really
irritate a population
and how it misrepresents.
'Cause there's different sides, right?
Where the package tours go
in Pattaya is gross.
It's disgusting.
Like, you can't even believe
this sh*t happens on planet earth.
And then there's other segments of
Thai society that are absolutely beautiful
and apart from that.
So I don't think Ukraine's
as extreme as that.
Like, Thailand's an extreme example, right?
But yeah, here,
there's that extraction mentality.
I think foreigners come in just to extract
and there's also foreigners that come in
that actually truly like and respect
the culture for what it is.
-For me, being polyamorous
this is a way worse place to be
than San Francisco.
Even though the women
are known for being beautiful here
automatic disqualification
a lot of the time.
-You're this polyamorous guy.
Where that doesn't really fly with women...
[chuckles] anywhere in the world.
Seriously.
And so you're on the front lines of it
in San Francisco, right?
And maybe there's...
I would give less than 1% of females
are gonna be okay with that.
Then you take it to a
culturally conservative part of the world
and
I think you sort of
come up to a steel wall.
If you're trying to be polyamorous in Kyiv.
So that, you've put yourself into...
Well, let's just say a harder climb
than you'd have at home.
-And despite that, I still love Ukraine.
-Cool Juke, well...
Dude, I would like to recap this
in like a year and see where you're at
'cause I think, like....
I think when you put yourself
in a completely different environment
personal growth comes exponentially.
Like, I feel a year and
a couple months here, that's all it's been.
I've grown in so many areas.
I've learned so much.
I've been challenged
in so many different ways
but if I was at home
it would've been, like, this much
growth and learning.
Where here is, like, this much.
You've been a good bro in this journey
and if it wasn't...
...for you, if we didn't have each other
neither of us would be here I don't think.
-In a way.
-Yeah.
-Not that we need each other to stay here
but the conversation started
over a breakfast
and you were thinking of it
and I was supporting it
and then you planted the seed in my head.
-And I came and visited.
-After you planted it in mine.
-Yeah, after... Yeah, exactly.
So...
Right on, brother.
-Kind of like made a nice little comfy
landing pad for you in the apartment.
-Yeah, you did.
It was like, what is that weapon?
-Where it's got the...
-The grappling hook or something?
-Grappling hook, right, and I just came
over on the line and landed in.
You did all the hard work, so thanks, man.